>> Our solution for parsing the atlas definition is pretty straightforward.
First, we're given atlasJSON data that's been loaded from an xhr request. The
first step that we need to do is actually go through and call JSON.parse on
that. This will turn the text JSON data into an actual JavaScript object with
members and values that we can iterate over. We use this to affect here. The
parsed object has a frames dictionary that we'll actually iterate over to load
all of our sprites. We'd like to fetch each key inside of our dictionary. And
then, fetch the associated sprite object that comes with it. From here, we now
have the sprite name and effectively, the sprite values. The next step we take
here is to actually define the center of the image. So, we actually multiply the
width and the height times 0.5, which would give us the half width and half
height. Now, we store this value in the cx and cy as a negative offset. The
reason for this is that we'll use the cx and cy values a little later on, during
rendering, to transform our object into proper space. We store them as negatives
here so that we don't have to do the mathematics later on when we're drawing the
image. Once we've got this data, we go ahead forward and call the defSprite
function, passing in the image name as a key. And then, the frame.x, frame.y
with height and center data that you've already seen before.